welcome to this video a spin doors yo
and maybe I can do this start with e 60
I get the French I can that doesn't
happen so often I was speculating on a
on a stone wall Dutch so let's see
classical French okay what is this I
don't really remember playing him a six
and p5 is currently in fashion but also
this move an invention by rossovich with
b6 coming away that that's an early age
for that basically sacrifices the pawn
down ok so I think I'm taking it I mean
it looks it always dangerous to open the
H bar but check I cannot cannot really
believe in that maybe in blitz you can
can afford this kind of thing but check
my doubts so what now if I take on d4 I
play Queen to be six maybe it's Quinn d3
queen bee three for mating mating threat
um if I go go in to be 68 immediately
maybe this is this is an idea the
castles long nighty form before looks
very unnatural yeah so g6 can also not
probably not but g6
g6 I guess
young and aged five I guess it's not not
much else
okay so i can insert this check there
are only three and that was one thing
that our letter thought them is quite
quite necessary and good because I'm he
has problems with castling after that
but he always has rook age three this is
very annoying rook to age three yeah
it's going to be dangerous for me Jeff I
mean you just blundered the H porn but
it's just them it's not clear it's
simply not clear this position I still
think I should should give the check
they're so cheap now I look aged three
years the problem ma'am maybe it was bad
to give the check I don't know he's so
quick yeah roocase Rienzi form Wow
I have to go here is there some way to
defend this rook g3 King g7 queen age 5
rook h8 this may be holding okay man
he's just playing although as usual just
instant moves instead of trying to
really play good moves but it might it
might be sufficient okay Jade I don't
get that one I'm up for Luke h1 isn't
this some kind of a problem I mean
Jeff okay Jeff
yeah so I'm objectively winning now but
still it's not not easy because of my
really shaky King position how am i
winning though is there a way to make it
easier maybe you start with this so he
has to react to that I guess yeah so I
can also check and he always has I would
like to use the Queen there for the
defense probably Queen d8 should be
right just to be be closed and cover f6
so possibly night to c5 is a move then
yum so I thought Queen e7 now i can
check Queen f7 ok let's try to be quick
their place a little bit it can take c6
yeah he's getting many pawns this is
really really the case so let's do this
I got a ton of pawns already for the
rook
I shouldn't have given given him so many
pawns really quite quite clearly that
wasn't that wasn't great okay rook b6
blunders this bishop unfortunately so
where am I going if I go Bishop g4
actually for Ruby 60s Queen 88 okay
that's not helping them okay just take
him I have Luke age one check possibly
King be to our queen a three chick Queen
III chick time warning yeah let's check
start with that what does he chatters
have for Queen f6 check in some
situations I'm angling for Queen B 6 cm
that that was my point here with the
checks okay let's do this
Bishop g4 is an additional check then
possibly rookie and yet with you Alex
and then hook the aid is an a number of
pins now so it's threatening no check at
the moment there's some way to me to do
this should stay in the pin not clear
little Tommy ax king g3 as a good move
though now that I think of it probably
Kings you three is good maybe
87 so just a 7 that was the idea right I
was really thinking what is his idea
just havin of course a genetic yeah yeah
what a stupid game to lose very stupid
yeah come on I should I resign yeah
problem anybody will win this with four
pawns and everything yeah come on I'd
your tickler just responded to a
seven-year and yeah I mean of course the
funny thing is okay first of all he
blunders the H porn of course Jack it is
it's just a little bit of a little bit
of compensation and it gets very serious
now maybe I should have played age six
or something should be three years
really am really a problem or f5 is
maybe a move maybe f5 I don't know well
here it gets very problematic in here
and I think probably the check is just a
mistake yeah just a mistake because I'm
yeah and here here this is this is just
this is maybe okay but why not I don't
know this this and I don't get don't get
rook to e3 played in a second this is
just because like Queen g5 or g4 I'm
just getting killed I mean I just I
don't know good this is also winning a
angling for Bishop g6 this is what is
the computer giving plus seven yeah
instead he does this and now I'm a fine
again of course yeah okay rook h8 check
check yeah and this is this is tricky
now what is this actually it's got two
points for the for the route p.m. but my
coordination is really not good the
engine is on equal funny enough really
is on equal
nineteen ninety-four would win 94 wins
that's crazy I a c6 is also hanging this
is the problem yeah this is a I mean
okay well it wasn't necessary at all
what he did I mean as we can t determine
she would have won quite easily but this
is still dangerous far more dangerous
than I then I believed it to be okay
here check check now he shot his gun
this is this ton of pawns can t really
think it should be good but it's still I
mean he's got five points for the rook
he had quindi Asia we both missed tons
of tons of moves them okay went here
yeah and it's so difficult here to play
wow I thought there should be something
because of the pin and so on but I
cannot go i mean this is this looks nice
but still 96 I have to stay in the pin
and I don't know can I somehow continue
here Luke 64 is still continuing the
game with just a slight advantage in
wide Marrakech just blundered into e 7
which is kind of embarrassing yeah what
a strange game that means um so where do
i improve them I mean check that that is
simply not that cannot be good for white
it's simply simply not possible check
but where exactly do i improve so maybe
this was wrong I was thinking of this
and Queen B 6 but I thought Queen d3s
awkward or not awkward but I thought it
gives him some compensation but actually
this is probably what I should do in
comparison to the game when you had
Bishop d3 I go eight let's say I go age
6 cm
and he castles yeah this is good for
black gown that's good for black he
cannot quickly get in sacrifice their
and a move like this is actually quite
awkward threatening here don't I don't
really see how he covers the pawn I mean
you can go g3 but then 95 is good and
after a winter ATM and basically just
winning the the only danger here is
checkmater but it's a serious danger
Bishop d3 was strong maybe I should can
I go at five here this is an interesting
news if he takes maybe queen bee to some
some crazy line like that that might be
feasible yeah but I think 94 was better
I was wasn't really seeing Bishop d3
that this is fairly fairly strong this
is already very dangerous and one or two
more mistakes as we have seen led to a
white win and even with them with the
check even with that that that bad move
was still dangerous yeah he could he
could go for this and they said this is
sacrificed Luke against two pawns and
still had a very dangerous attack okay
well thanks for watching